Draw a rectangle
ABCD in the coordinate plane.
The three of the top of the rectangle are the following.
The coordinates are given.
What are the coordinates of point D?
Okay, a good way to get started is like
just put these three tips that are given to us.
It seems they are in the first quadrant, so
I will focus the coordinate axes on the first quadrant.
This will be the axis.
And this will be the axis x.
Let's see.
The highest x value I have,
I have two, I have five, I have five,
it looks like we're going to five.
I could say one,
two, three, four and five.
So, that's five, I can just write
one, two, three, four and five.
Let's see, the highest value,
I have one, one and six.
We're up to six.
One two Three,
four, five, and six.
I can mark them with numbers.
One, two, three, four, five and six.
Now let's put the dots.
Let us first put point A, which has coordinates two and one.
x is equal to two, y is equal to one.
Hence this is the point.
Now let's apply point B.
Point B is at five and one.
So x is equal to five, y is equal to one.
That's right there.
Now let us apply point C.
Point C, maybe I have to find another color for her.
Point C is equal to five, equal to six.
x is equal to five, y is equal to six.
This takes us almost there.
And now we have to find where point D will be.
Well D will be ...
This is a rectangle.
The sides are parallel, all the peaks,
we have right angles at all peaks.
So point D will have the same x coordinate
such as this point here.
So it will have the same x coordinate.
She will have the coordinate x, let me write it.
D will have the x coordinate in two.
And she will have the same coordinate
as this point above.
Therefore, it will have a y coordinate equal to six.
Six.
So D will be at point two and six.
You see that by doing this,
we formed a nice rectangle.
We can draw a rectangle,
this is one side, this is the upper side,
this is the other side, the other side.
And then draw it this way.
Here, we received the rectangle,
but more importantly, we have answered the question,
what are the coordinates of point D. OK.